on the finish line don't forget it
we are democrats and we're ready to lead
again
we're coming together on august 17th all
across america
be there
and now live from milwaukee mayor tom
barrett
hi everybody i'm tom barrett the proud
mayor of milwaukee
i would love to be welcoming you to my
home city
right now the good people of milwaukee
and i were so
excited when we learned that our
resilient city
was chosen to host the 2020 democratic
national convention
it was the first time a major political
party
chose wisconsin to hold this convention
but these are not conventional times and
as a result
as we all know this is not a
conventional convention
and as much as we would have loved to
host you in person
i am proud that the democratic party and
the city of milwaukee
have made the health of our residents
our number one priority unlike the
president
we've never called covid19 a hoax
unlike the president we've never made
fun of face masks
and unlike the president we've never
belittled
our public health experts we understand
why we can't be together this week
and i hope you do too and as our party
comes together virtually
to nominate joe biden to be our next
president
we're showing the country that we're
nominating a leader who
isn't afraid to make tough choices or to
work with
health experts not against them to
address this pandemic
milwaukee is a very special place on
america's fresh coast
i look forward to the day when you are
all able to come experience
our beautiful lakefront our historic
neighborhoods
and above all our diverse hardworking
and friendly residents
but in the meantime it is my honor
to call the second session of the 48th
quadrennial national convention
of the democratic party to order
delegates we will now hear reports from
our three convention standing committees
to start us off i'm pleased to introduce
lorraine miller
and james roosevelt jr co-chairs of the
credentials committee
to present their committee's report
hello delegates to the 2020 democratic
national convention
my name is jim roosevelt and it is an
honor to have served as a co-chair of
the credentials committee
along with my good friend lorraine
miller
pursuant to the convention rules the
credentials committee met and took
action
to approve the credentials of the
delegates and alternates that have been
credentialed for the 2020 democratic
national convention
i am proud to say that all credentials
issues were resolved
in accordance with the actions of the
credentials committee
this year's nominating process reflects
the efforts of so many
to make our process more open and more
transparent
as a result we know that our delegates
reflect the best of our party
and we are all united around our
nominees
joe biden and kamala harris
may i add my thanks for the opportunity
to serve
as a co-chair of the credentials
committee with my friend jim roosevelt
our state and territorial parties have
worked
diligently in these unprecedented times
to make sure that their delegations
reflect
the great diversity of our party
we are proud that our party places a
priority on making sure
that participants of this convention
highlight
a core value of our party that is
ensuring that all americans regardless
of sex race age
color creed national origin
religion economic status
sexual orientation gender identity
ethnic identity or physical
disability have a role in this
important process mr chair
i am pleased to report that the
credentials committee report
was approved by committee members
and all delegates have been fully
credentialed thank you lorraine and jim
we will now hear from the co-chairs of
the rules committee
maria cadona and congressman bonnie
frank to present that committee's report
buenas noches my name is maria cardona
and i am so honored to serve as co-chair
of the rules and bylaws committee
of the democratic national convention
along with my friend and colleague
congressman barney frank the rules
committee met
the last week of july to adopt the
convention
rules of procedure officers and agenda
the committee approved the rules that
will govern the convention
these rules are based on a long-standing
process
that has governed our conventions for
many many cycles
given the unprecedented nature of the
coven-19 health crisis
these rules that were approved focus on
providing for a convention
that will transform the convention
experience for delegates and for
participants
and will allow for maximum participation
by those delegates the rules committee
also ratified a dynamic
group of democrats to serve as the
officers of the convention
the convention officers truly represent
the ideals
and the principles of the democratic
party
these actions of the rules committee
will ensure
that the 2020 democratic national
convention can efficiently
and effectively proceed with its
important business
the rules committee also took action on
a resolution
that was recommended for approval by
convention delegates
the resolution calls on the democratic
national committee
to continue the work from this cycle to
improve our nominating process
and to build on those reforms for the
2024 cycle
the resolution calls on the dnc rules
committee
to conduct a comprehensive review of the
presidential nominating reforms
that were made and to evaluate where
even further reforms might be needed
this review and accounting will be
complete by march 31st
2021 chair i am pleased to report that
the unity resolution
was approved by the delegates thank you
to the delegates
thank you to the members of the rules
and bylaws committee
and thank you for continuing to do
everything you can
to ensure we are successful in november
gracias two things about the rules are
very important to note
one they continue and build on the trend
towards
making our nominating process as
democratic as possible with a small deed
we have asked that we go to primaries
rather than caucuses
we have restricted and maintained those
restrictions on non-elected delegates
secondly it's important to note that
everything in these rules
is the product of a very free agreement
between the sanders and biden people as
it was last time
between clinton and sanders that is we
have a very democratic set of rules
agreed upon enthusiastically by both
camps
thank you maria and bernie it's my
pleasure to call
on platform committee co-chairs julie
chavez rodriguez
and dennis madonna to present their
committee's report
good evening i'm julie chavez-rodriguez
and alongside my friend
dennis mcdonough i was honored to
co-chair
this year's democratic platform
committee
this spring the process for drafting our
2020 democratic platform
began with the formation of the unity
task forces
appointed by vice president biden and
senator sanders
the task forces focused their work on
six major
policy priorities continuing the work of
the task forces
the platform drafting committee engaged
voters
and encouraged them to share their
stories so that their values were
reflected the platform drafting
committee
chaired by mayor kisha lance bottoms
engaged so many throughout our party to
ensure
that that feedback was incorporated
whether it was received online
or through allied groups thanks julie
i'm dennis mcdonough and i'm proud to
have been julie's co-chair
on the platform committee our committee
has produced a platform
that proposes solutions to the
challenges that american families face
in this unprecedented time
it's informed by the values of our party
and the priorities of our
presidential nominee vice president joe
biden
i strongly believe that this platform
lays out an agenda
informed by the values that will defeat
donald trump
and heal the soul of our nation the
united states of america
thank you julie and dennis thank you to
all the members of all three standing
committees
for your important work to ensure we
have a smooth and orderly convention
a platform that represents our party's
values and interests
and a plan for continuing to look at how
we
conduct our affairs in the best spirit
of openness fairness and inclusion
[Music]
[Music]
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic to which it stands
one nation
one nation one nation one nation
under god indivisible
my fellow americans
this is my country
many of us have fought hard for the
right to say that
many are now struggling today
from the harlem so that they may say
this with conviction
this is our country
[Music]
[Applause]
we are a people in a quandary about the
present
we are a people in search of our future
[Music]
we must make the american people hear
our tale of two cities we must convince
them
that we don't have to settle for two
cities that we can have
one city indivisible shining for all of
its people
if you give us a chance we can perform
after all ginger rogers did everything
that fred astaire did
she just did it backwards and in high
[Applause]
heels
there is not a liberal america and a
conservative america
there is the united states of america
there is not a black america and a white
america
and latino america and asian america
there's the united states
of america
the american dream is not a sprint
or even a marathon
our families don't always cross the
finish line in the span of one
generation
but each generation passes on to the
next the fruits of their labor
we are one people all of us pledging
allegiance to the stars and stripes
all of us defending the united states of
america
[Applause]
welcome welcome welcome to the second
night of the democratic national
convention
this is a different kind of convention
look at the camera and smile
and this this is a different kind of
keynote it's a different kind of keynote
this year and we've got a lot to say
let's get real there's a lot riding on
this election when we're facing the
biggest economic and health crisis in
generations
because our president didn't and still
doesn't have a plan
when doctors nurses and home health care
aides in philadelphia
have to risk their own lives to protect
others
because there's not enough protective
equipment when factory workers in ohio
are faced with dangerous
conditions because this administration
hasn't given clear guidance on how to
protect our people
when teachers in gwinnett county georgia
and across the country are being asked
to return to the classroom
without a plan to keep them safe and
parents are exhausted
juggling full-time work and full-time
child care
and visiting our parents and
grandparents
through the window of a nursing home
worrying all the time that they'll get
sick
when unemployment in north charleston
south carolina
a city i represent has risen nearly
four-fold
and evictions are putting families out
on the street
in the middle of a pandemic make no
mistake
it didn't have to be this bad in the
early days of the virus
donald trump didn't listen to the
experts and that he said something that
a president
should never say he said i don't take
responsibility
at all no responsibility no leadership
no plan
he still doesn't have a plan donald
trump just doesn't understand
we can't fix our economy until we get a
hold of the virus
while working families are struggling
he's looking out for the people who are
already doing just fine
the wealthy the big corporations the
donors to his campaign
he's looking out for himself but there's
one person
who's looking out for us all of us and
that's joe biden
joe called it we are in a battle for the
soul
of our nation but joe knows we can never
let hard times
turn us against each other and we can
never stop doing the hard work
to make things right that's why we ran
for office
even when people died even when there
had
never been a latina in the nevada state
senate
or a democrat elected as florida
commissioner of agriculture
in nearly three decades or an openly gay
man in the georgia state legislature
when birmingham hadn't had a mayor this
young in 120 years
we ran for office because we know the
struggles
american families are facing because
we've lived them
we've lived the insecurity and the
indignity
of an eviction notice i like many of you
have lived the frustration of paying off
student loans
we have lived the grief of losing loved
ones to gun violence
and the criminal justice system that
unfairly targets
our communities we have lived that
feeling of helplessness
when someone you love is very sick and
access to healthcare is a matter of life
and death
by the way joe biden has lived a lot of
this too
he was raised in a middle class family
in scranton pennsylvania in clemont
delaware
he watched his dad look for work and
learned that a job is about so
much more than a paycheck it's about
dignity
and respect he was sworn into office
from the hospital room
of his two young sons after a car crash
killed his wife and infant daughter
he knows what it's like to thank god you
have health care
he knows what it's like to work hard for
everything you've got
he knows what it's like to send a child
off to war
and he'll never forget who he's fighting
for
i look around my district in north texas
i see the people who built this country
the educators like the single mom who
raised me
the men and women on the front lines of
our health care system you built this
country
small business owners like the ones
whose shops and restaurants
line the streets of birmingham michigan
charleston south carolina of tribal
nations
line the streets of philadelphia and
bring our communities to life
you built this country the nurses in
memphis who came out of retirement to
treat patients during this pandemic
you built this country and you know what
you deserve more than the constant chaos
that donald trump delivers
you deserve health care you can afford a
job that pays you fairly you deserve
child care and paid sick leave while you
work
and when you pay into social security
and medicare you deserve to know it will
be there
when you retire and thanks to the voters
across the country
in both red states and blue states
a new generation of leaders is rising up
and with joe biden in the white house
there's no limit to what we can do
in nevada we're making drug prices more
transparent
so people with chronic illnesses won't
go broke
while drug companies get rich joe's
working to protect and expand the
affordable care act
he'll make sure millions of people keep
their coverage and no one can be denied
for a pre-existing condition
he'll bring down the cost of health care
and prescription drugs too
giving tax credits to working families
and allowing medicare to negotiate drug
prices
that's a big effing deal that's a big
deal because joe knows we can't have a
healthy economy
if people can't afford health care but
let's remember
donald trump is suing to take health
care coverage away
from more than 20 million americans and
eliminate protections
for over a hundred million with
pre-existing conditions
in texas we're standing up for fierce
women like my mom
and my dias who raised me to never back
down from a tough fight
so we're fighting to make sure that
mothers have access to health screenings
for safe pregnancies and childbirth and
we're bringing
long overdue justice to survivors of
sexual assault
joe biden has been fighting for women
his entire career
as senator he authored the violence
against women act
and as president he'll restore funding
for planned parenthood
he will codify roe v wade and make
reducing maternal mortality
especially for women of color a top
priority
in florida on the front lines of our
climate crisis
we're working to produce more renewable
energy and shrink
our carbon footprint joe has a major
plan
to invest in clean energy jobs and
infrastructure
in the house of representatives we're
closing loopholes
to ensure local infrastructure projects
use american-made materials and local
labor
and support american manufacturing
unlike donald trump
joe biden will actually enforce buy
american rules
investing in american-made clean energy
building materials high-tech equipment
and r
d all creating more good jobs
in michigan we're banning business
practices that have exploited workers
and cost them hundreds of millions of
dollars in lost wages
when unemployment is the highest rate
since the great depression when millions
of people have seen their
hours and pay slash joe knows it's not
enough to rebuild the economy the way it
was before
we've got to build it back better
he'll build an economy that rewards work
not wealth
and get rid of the trump tax cuts that
only benefit big corporations
and the rich and then he'll invest in
health care
education and infrastructure and in
getting small businesses
up and running again take it from me
when you're in the trenches
you want joe biden right there next to
you when i wanted to marry the man i
loved
joe biden was the first national figure
to support me and my family
appreciate you man when the auto
industry was going under
joe stuck his neck out to protect it and
helped save
one and a half million auto jobs when
our economy was on the brink
joe led the recovery effort that created
millions of jobs
including here in western pennsylvania
under his leadership
america bounced back with the longest
economic expansion
in history you know the one trump brags
about creating
that's what happens when joe piden is in
your corner
working families get a fair shot he
understands that leadership means
fighting for the people who built this
country
all of you this nation
belongs to all of us and in every
election
we choose how we will create a more
perfect union
not by taking sides but by taking stock
of where we are and what we need this
year's choice could not be more clear
america faces a triple threat a public
health
catastrophe an economic collapse
and a reckoning with racial justice and
inequality
so our choice is clear a steady
experienced public servant
who can lead us out of this crisis just
like he's done before
or a man who only knows how to deny and
distract
a leader who cares about our families or
a president who only cares about
himself we know joe biden
america we need joe biden
to make your voice heard text vote to
30330
in a democracy we do not elect saviors
we cast our ballots for those who see
our struggles and pledge to serve
who hear our dreams and work to make
them real
who defend our way of life by protecting
our right to
vote faced with a president of cowardice
joe biden is a man of proven courage
he will restore our moral compass by
confronting our challenges
not by hiding from them or undermining
our elections
to keep his job in a time of voter
suppression at home
and authoritarians abroad joe biden will
be a champion
for free and fair elections for a public
health system
that keeps us safe for an economy that
we build back
better than before and for
accountability and
integrity in our system of justice
we stand with joe biden because this
isn't just about defeating donald
trump we are in this to win
for america so let's get it done
hello i'm tracee ellis ross and how
exciting to hear from young elected
leaders from across the country
a perfect way to begin night two of the
democratic national convention
uniting america tonight is
all about leadership this unprecedented
moment
calls for leadership steady
inclusive leadership driven by people
who understand that our democracy is
based on the value of each and every one
of us being treated with dignity
and respect leaders who respond to the
needs of hard-working americans who
right this minute
are unable to pay rent put food on the
table and keep their loved ones safe
as a black woman i find myself at a
crucial intersection
in american politics for far too long
black female leadership in this country
has been utilized
without being acknowledged or valued
but we are turning the tide
hello kamala her nomination
is historic for anyone who believes
in we the people like senator harris and
many we saw in the keynote today's
leaders emerge from communities that
have long been underrepresented they're
charting new paths
in the spirit of shirley chisholm
charlotta bass
fannie lou hamer and john lewis
they get in good trouble necessary
trouble they
call things out otherwise ignored
elevating our nation
and changing the course of our lives for
the better
with every vote we cast for forward
thinking
honest leaders we chip away at ingrained
systems of inequity
and we bend the arc of justice
true leaders make sure that policy is
informed by
all of us bridging our burden
past to a safe equitable
and even joyful future joe biden and
kamala harris are that bridge
heeding voices from within the movement
for racial justice
listening to the people and acting with
empathy
and compassion to reflect our shared
humanity
tonight we'll hear from a number of
american leaders including former acting
u.s attorney general sally yates who
refused to defend an unconstitutional
travel ban
and paid for it with her job
a threat to this nation to our democracy
is real
it's clear in his prison you've watched
the president now for three years
look at what he's doing instilling fear
i mean not not joking instilling fear
sowing divisions stroking racial
division
undercutting every institution that was
designed to check the abuse of power
by the president or anyone else all this
for what reason
all this in order to solidify his face
and expand his power
good evening i'm sally yates speaking at
a political convention is something i
never expected to be doing but the
future
of our democracy is at stake
i'm here in my hometown of atlanta where
as a young lawyer i joined our nation's
justice department
for nearly 30 years through democratic
and republican administrations
i worked alongside my doj colleagues to
advance our nation's promise
of equal justice i served as deputy
attorney general in the obama biden
administration
and stayed on as acting attorney general
for the trump transition
then ten days in i was fired for
refusing to defend
president trump's shameful and unlawful
muslim travel ban that was the start of
his relentless attacks on our democratic
institutions and
countless dedicated public servants
like me these officials didn't swear an
oath to a person
or a party public servants promised to
defend our constitution
uphold our laws and work on behalf
of the american people but from the
moment president trump took office
he's used his position to benefit
himself
rather than our country he's trampled
the rule of law
trying to weaponize our justice
department to attack his enemies and
protect his friends
rather than standing up to vladimir
putin
he fawns over a dictator who is still
trying to interfere
in our elections he's even trying to
sabotage our postal service
to keep people from being able to vote
his
constant attacks on the fbi the free
press
inspectors general federal judges they
all have one purpose
to remove any check on his abuse of
power
put simply he treats our country
like it's his family business this time
bankrupting our nation's moral authority
at home and abroad
but our country doesn't belong to him it
belongs to all of
us joe biden embraces that
he has spent his entire life putting our
country
first he has never backed down from a
challenge
or a bully he summons the best in us
and lives by the values that define us
as americans
service integrity courage
compassion there are countless stories
of joe biden reaching out to someone
in their moment of need well this is our
country's
moment of need we need a president who
respects our laws and the
privilege of public service
who reflects our values and cares about
our people
we need a president who will restore the
soul of america
we need joe biden
over the last four years we have
experienced failed leadership under
donald
j trump we've had to deal with this
insanity i've watched our country
deteriorate
the cover-ups the lying the favoritism
you disregard for the constitution
donald trump has
failed america it is time for us to
reclaim our constitutional and
democratic values we need to prove to
the world and
most importantly prove to ourselves that
we are better than this
we need an experienced leader a leader
that has passion
integrity and strategic leadership
skills and his name is joe biden joe
biden
joe biden is that leader and he really
wants the best for this country
he understands and respects our
democracy the rule of law
and the u.s constitution he will move
toward
creating a more perfect union
hi this is senator chuck schumer
democratic leader
from my hometown brooklyn new york
behind me is a sight i see out of my
window
every night the statue of liberty the
same sight
that greeted hopeful immigrants like my
grandparents
a symbol of freedom and a beacon of hope
to the world
today donald trump has divided our
country
diminished our greatness and demeaned
everything
that this statue represents he even
hidden a bunker
as americans were tear gassed and beaten
millions are jobless 170 000 americans
have died from covet
and donald trump says it is what it is
president should never say it is what it
is president lincoln
honoring the great sacrifice at
gettysburg didn't say
it is what it is president roosevelt
seeing a third of the nation ill house
still clad and ill-nourished
didn't say it is what it is america
donald trump has quit on you
we need a president with dignity
integrity and the experience to lead us
out of this crisis
a man with a steady hand and a big heart
who will never
ever quit on america that man
is my friend joe biden he will be a
great president
but if we're going to win this battle
for the soul of our nation
joe can't do it alone democrats must
take back the senate we will stay united
from sanders and warren to mansion and
warner
and with our unity we will bring bold
and dramatic change
to our country let me tell you some of
the things we do
with president biden vice president
harris and a democratic majority
we will make health care affordable for
all
we'll undo the vicious inequality of
income and wealth
that has plagued america for far too
long and will take strong
decisive action to combat climate change
and save the planet
we will protect voting rights fight
systemic
racism in the criminal justice system
and in our economy
and restore a supreme court that looks
out for people
not corporations we'll rebuild our
infrastructure and make sure
every home from inner city to rural
america
has broadband we will save the post
office
and once and for all defeat covet 19
this evil disease and
beckoned by the lady behind us we will
reform our immigration system so that
immigrants
yearning to breathe free will at last
become
american citizens together
we can reignite the hope once felt by
millions of men and women
huddled masses on creaking ships who
glimpsed this mighty women woman with
her torch
knowing they could build a better life
here
in america and out of this long
national nightmare america will finally
awaken
to a brighter future and a new day
senator chuck schumer reminding us that
leadership requires integrity
and accountability real leaders don't
ask
what we can do for them they ask what
they can do for us
in a minute we will hear from two former
presidents
and they're going to speak to that but
first here are caroline kennedy and her
son
jack schlossberg 60 years ago
in a crowded la stadium my father
accepted the democratic nomination for
president
he challenged americans to look to the
future and join him on a journey toward
a new frontier
it was a call to the young at heart
regardless of age or party
times have changed but the themes of my
grandfather's speech
courage unity and patriotism are as
important today
as they were in 1960 and once again we
need a leader who believes america's
best days are yet to come
we need joe biden i've admired joe biden
since i was a senate intern
in 1974. he shared my uncle teddy's
commitment
to civil rights women's rights and
working families
he was a senator who cared who led who
inspired
that's why i helped choose him to be
barack obama's running mate in 2008.
when i was u.s ambassador to japan i got
to see vice president biden in action
he stepped off air force two wearing his
aviator glasses and a big smile
radiating american optimism and
generosity
i saw a leader who was tough but fair
who commanded the trust and respect of
other nations
and who always put america's interests
first
joe biden's lifetime of public service
reflects his unwavering commitment to
our highest
ideals in this election our future is on
the ballot
for my generation it will define the
rest of our lives
we need to tackle climate change we need
to end systemic racial injustice
we need to make health care available
for everybody and we need to rebuild an
economy
that helps working families we can do
this we can reach these new frontiers
but only with a president who asks what
he can do for our country
and what together we can do to build a
better world it's up to us
let's get it done let's elect joe biden
the next president of the united states
it's a great pleasure for jimmy and me
to join you in celebrating our next
president of the united states joe biden
we've known and admired joe and jill for
many years
and most recently i've worked with him
on tackling the demands faced by the
more than 53 million
unpaid caregivers in our country who are
juggling
work and other family responsibilities
and putting their own
physical and mental health and
well-being
at risk joe knows well too well
the sorrows and struggles of being a
family caregiver
from joe's time as a young widower
thrust into single parenthood
with a demanding job to he and jill
caring for their own parents and has um
vote at the end of their lives
he knows caregiving is hard even on the
good days
jill and i also know the challenges of
caregiving for those who served in the
military and returned with
visible and invisible wounds and we know
those caregivers need a leader in the
white house
jimmy and i are voting for joe because
he recognizes
the challenges facing our families
and has the heart and the talent to make
life better
for all americans
[Music]
when i ran for president in 1976 joe
biden was my first and most effective
supporter in the center
for decades he has been my loyal and
dedicated friend
joe has the experience character and
decency to bring us together
and restore america's greatness we
deserve a person with integrity
and judgment someone who's honest and
fair someone who is committed
to what is best for the american people
joe is that kind of leader
and he is the right person for this
moment in our nation's history
he understands that i understand dignity
our senseless rates
they determine not only our vision but
our actions
more than ever that's what we need
during these uncertain times nobody
realizes that many american lives can be
saved each day
through the use of mass and testing as
recommended by our medical experts
[Music]
joe biden must be our next president
[Music]
good evening a presidential election is
the world's most important job interview
at the end we hire a leader to help us
solve problems create opportunities
and give our kids better tomorrows it's
a tall order this year
with the covet 19 outbreak on a path to
killing 200 000 people
and destroying millions of jobs and
small businesses
how did donald trump respond at first he
said the virus was under control
and would soon disappear when it didn't
he was on tv every day bragging on what
a great job he was doing
when our scientists waited to give us
vital information
when he didn't like the expert advice he
was given he ignored it
only when covet exploded and even more
states that he encouraged people to wear
masks
by then many more were dying when asked
about the surgeon deaths
he shrugged and said it is what it is
but did it have to be this way no
code hit us much harder than it had to
we have just four percent of the world's
population 25 percent of the world's
covenant cases
our unemployment rate is more than twice
as high as south korea's
two and a half times the united
kingdom's more than three times japan
donald trump says we're leading the
world well we are the only major
industrial economy
to have its unemployment rate tripled at
a time like this the oval office should
be
a command center instead it's a storm
center
there's only chaos just one thing never
changes
his determination to deny responsibility
and shift the blame
the buck never stops there
now you have to decide whether to renew
his contract or hire someone else
if you want a president who defines the
job of spending hours a day watching tv
and zapping people on social media he's
your man
denying distracting and demeaning works
great if you're trying to entertain or
inflame
but in a real crisis it collapses like a
house of cards
kova just doesn't respond to any of that
to beat it you've got to actually go to
work and deal with the facts
our party is united in offering you a
very different choice
a go to work president a down to earth
get the job done guy
a man with a mission to take
responsibility not shift the blame
concentrate not distract unite not
divide
our choice is joe biden joe helped bring
us back from a recession before
and he can do it again in 2009 barack
obama and joe biden started with the
worst economy
since the great depression and when they
were done
they delivered more than six straight
years of job growth
what did joe do he accepted
responsibility for implementing the
recovery act
his work created a lot of new jobs and
started
many new companies in communities across
our country
now joe's committed to building america
back again
how he's given us smart detailed plans
to invest in areas vital to our future
innovative financing for modern
factories and small businesses
good jobs and green energy and
conservation to combat climate change
a modern infrastructure that brings
small town and rural america the
connectivity and investment
others take for granted and to plan to
ensure
that black americans latino americans
native americans
women immigrants and other communities
left behind
are full participants in our economy and
our society
joe biden wants to build an economy far
better suited
to our changing world better for young
people
better for families working and raising
their kids better for people who lost
jobs and need new ones
better for farmers tired of being
collateral damage in trade wars
better for workers caring for the sick
elderly and people with disabilities
better because of a living wage and
access to affordable higher education
and health care
including prescription drugs and to
child care a secure retirement
and for the first time paid family and
medical leave
joe won't just put his signature on a
check and try to fool you into thinking
it came from him
he'll work to make sure that your
paycheck reflects your contribution to
and your stake in a growing economy in
this job interview
the difference is stark you know what
donald trump will do with four more
years
blame bully and belittle and you know
what joe biden will do
bill back better it's trump's us versus
them america
against joe biden's america where we all
live and work together
it's a clear choice the future of our
country's riding on it
thank you
it's time to call the role and
officially nominate the democratic
candidate for president of the united
states
but this year for the first time the
roll call is heading out to
all 57 states and territories
places that showcase our nation's
natural beauty
places where people are working together
to secure a better future for our
country in places
that are working to rebuild and recover
like iowa where thousands have been left
homeless and hundreds of thousands
have been left without power in the wake
of last week's terrible storm
our hearts are with you iowa there's so
much going on right now
tonight we come together to nominate a
candidate who will fight for all of us
the convention delegates will do the
official nominating but you can join
them in supporting joe biden
text join to 30330
to get involved and now the chair of the
democratic national committee
tom perez
it's great to be here in milwaukee a
proud union town whose grit and
character
reflect the resilience of our party and
our country
there's no doubt these last few months
have been tough but good leadership
means being able to adapt to any
situation
and i want to thank the people of
milwaukee for being such gracious and
flexible hosts
it's also great to be back in wisconsin
where i was lucky enough to marry my
wife anne marie a little more than three
decades ago
the progressive movement has deep roots
here and since today is the 100th
anniversary of the 19th amendment's
ratification
we should point out that wisconsin was
the first state to ratify it
what's more in its one-word motto
forward wisconsin captures something
so important about america the way that
no matter what challenges today brings
we
always believe a better future is
possible
that's what my parents believed when
they emigrated to this country nearly a
century ago
fleeing the iron fist of a brutal
dictator in the dominican republic
this nation welcomed them with
compassion
and they quickly learned that their hope
of building a better life through hard
work
was shared by generations of americans
indeed
every american story is a story about
that hope
that sense of possibility it's what
unites us
defines us and it's what sustains
us now we will work to meet our
extraordinary challenges because
progress is made by the hopeful
not the cynical and we will do that work
together because
movements are built by the many not the
few
and as you watch tonight's decidedly
unconventional roll call
and reflect on the diversity of our
nation
remember you too are part
of the american story and no matter
where you come
from or where you're watching from
tonight
you have a place in joe biden's
democratic party
delegates and distinguished guests under
our procedural rules
two democratic candidates submitted
nominating documents
to our convention secretary for the
office of president of the united states
senator bernie sanders and vice
president joe biden
as such each candidate has provided
names of individuals
who will make nominating and seconding
speeches on their behalf
we will begin with nominating and
seconding speeches
for senator sanders speaking on his
behalf will be
two progressive champions bob king
and representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez
i'm bob king as a proud union member and
former president
of a great american union the uaw i'm
honored to nominate bernie sanders for
president
for decades bernie has led the fight for
working families
fighting for workers rights to organize
unions and collectively bargain
in a time of enormous inequality he
understands
that we must confront large corporations
which have far
too much control over our economy and
our politics
bernie believes health care is a human
right and should not be contingent on a
job
he knows we can rebuild our crumbling
infrastructure by creating millions
of good paying union jobs while
combating climate change
bernie's moral clarity has emboldened
the democratic party's fight for justice
the grassroots energy of his supporters
has cemented
important advances in our platform
bernie will continue to leave a movement
that helps defeat trump
and delivers transformational change i'm
excited to plates in denomination the
name
of a great champion of the working class
senator bernie sanders
good evening bienvenidos and thank you
to everyone here today endeavoring
towards a better
more just future for our country and our
world
infidelity and gratitude to a mass
people's movement
working to establish 21st century social
economic and human rights including
guaranteed health care
higher education living wages and labor
rights
for all people in the united states
a movement striving to recognize and
repair
the wounds of racial injustice
colonization
misogyny and homophobia and to propose
and build reimagined systems of
immigration and foreign policy
that turn away from the violence and
xenophobia
of our past a movement that realizes
the unsustainable brutality of an
economy that rewards explosive
inequalities of
wealth for the few at the expense of
long-term stability for the many and who
organized a historic grassroots campaign
to reclaim our democracy in a time when
millions of people
in the united states are looking for
deep
systemic solutions to our crises of mass
evictions
unemployment and lack of health care in
el espirito del pueblo
and out of a love for all people i
hereby
second the nomination of senator bernard
sanders of vermont
for president of the united states of
america
thank you mr king and representative of
carcio cortez
we now turn to nominating and seconding
speeches
for vice president biden in a moment
we'll hear from senator chris coons
who holds the delaware senate seat once
held by the vice president
and representative lisa blunt rochester
my colleague in the house
but first we'll hear from jacqueline
asby
a working american who met joe biden in
a most
unexpected place the elevator where she
worked
i take powerful people up on my elevator
all the time
when they get off they go to their
important meetings
me i just head back to the lobby but in
the short time i spent with joe biden
i could tell he really saw me that he
actually cared
that my life meant something to him and
i knew
even when he went into his important
meeting he take my story in there with
him
that's because joe biden has room in his
heart
for more than just himself we've been
through a lot
and we have tough days ahead but
nominating someone like that
to be in the white house is a good place
to start
that's why i nominate my friend
joe biden as the next president of the
united states
i'm senator chris coons from delaware a
small state where people expect to see
their senators
and even sometimes their vice president
at the supermarket
at a church festival out in their
community joe fights for us because he
knows our struggles and hopes
he knows the pain of loss and the
worries of working parents
and he's always brought that same
personal concern he showed for
jacqueline
to getting things done as our senator
and then as president obama's
vice president joe's tackled gun
violence and climate change
he stood up to dictators and supported
our troops he led the recovery effort
after the last recession
and delivered on a promise to make our
health care system fairer
and stronger through it all joe biden's
never forgotten where he's from
he's been sustained by his faith and his
family through the toughest of times
and he has the heart and the compassion
for this moment
for all of these reasons and more it's
my
honor to second the nomination of my
good friend
joe biden to be the next president of
these united states
i'm congresswoman lisa blunt rochester
in some history class in the future
children are learning about this moment
they're learning about our pain our
grief
our worry but they're also learning
about a man named joe biden
about how he restored decency to our
government
and integrity to our democracy
their learning about how we conquered a
pandemic stood
united for racial justice and built our
economy back
better than before they're learning
about how his leadership
gave their generation a fighting chance
they're learning about us too about the
resolve and the unity we showed against
the forces of hatred and division
about the work we will do over the next
11 weeks
and about the night when despite our
distance
we came together to nominate joe biden
for president
of the united states a nomination i'm
honored to second
thank you all pursuant to our convention
rules
will now proceed to a roll call by
states
on the selection of our party's
candidate for the president
of the united states secretary ray
mr chairman coming to you live from the
wisconsin center it's time to begin our
virtual trip around america
our journey begins at the site of a
major step forward
in our national journey towards justice
let's go to alabama
john lewis marched across this bridge in
1965
to demand the right to vote a lifetime
later
civil rights and voting rights remain
america's great
unfinished business but those who walked
this path before us
showed us the way forward if we want to
honor john lewis's incredible life
let's restore the voting rights act and
ensure
that our democracy belongs to all
americans alabama casts eight votes for
bernie sanders
and the great state of alabama casts 52
votes
for our next president of these united
states
joe biden
alaska the waters we rely on to feed our
families and make a living are
threatened by climate change
when joe biden was vice president he and
president obama made sure
alaska's tribes had a say on how these
waters were managed
donald trump took it away we must elect
the president who will respect our
voices
protect our waters and address climate
change alaska cast seven votes bernie
sanders
and call votes for the next president
joe biden
american samoa joe biden honors our
service and we trust him to support our
community
as vice president he helped expand rural
infrastructure to communities like ours
broadening our economic capacity as
president
we will continue to strengthen rural
america from new england to the pacific
on behalf of the governor lolo matarashi
molinga and the american samoa
democratic party we proudly cast
11 votes for our next president of the
united states of america
joe biden arizona
as a middle school teacher i know public
educators are doing everything they can
to make sure our students have quality
learning experiences this fall
as a mother of a high school freshman i
know that it's far from perfect
as an nea union organizer i'll fight to
make sure that it's
scientists parents and educators that
decide when it's safe to go back to
school
not politicians as an arizona latina i
proudly cast our votes
29 for bernie sanders and 51 for our
next president
joe biden arkansas feeding people is an
act of love and i think we all
can use a little extra love these days
so we took our food trucks out into the
community to deliver meals
made right here at the clinton
presidential center for our neighbors in
need
even when our leaders let us down
america kept looking out for each other
arkansas casts nine votes for bernie
sanders and 27 votes for our next
president
joe biden california climate change is
not a hoax
it's real and communities of color have
been bearing the brunt
of this reality for generations joe
biden's plan to crack down
on polluters to protect our air and
water is about
environmental justice and economic
justice
he'll prioritize equity and bring new
clean energy jobs
to black and brown neighborhoods because
that is how we build back better
california home to our next vice
president kamala harris
cast 231 votes for bernie sanders
and 263 votes for our next president
joe biden colorado han and i grew up in
poverty as immigrants
but we've been able to make a decent
living we're extremely
lucky but now we have three family
members that tested positive for kovid
and it just doesn't feel safe to put
evan and emma back to school
this is certainly going to be hard on
them and on us
but millions of working families will
have it much harder
i know joe biden cares about these
struggles and that's why i trust him to
fight for us
with one abstention colorado will cast
36 votes for bernie sanders
and 42 for our next president joe biden
connecticut firefighters are proud to
put our lives on the line every day
to protect our neighbors it's a badge of
courage
but while we are protecting your family
we need a president who is committed
to protecting ours and that's joe biden
he has the courage we respect and the
commitment to working americans we need
now
on behalf of our governor ned lamont i
am honored to cast connecticut
75 votes for our next president joe
biden delaware
delaware passes
delaware passes democrats abroad we
represent the millions of americans who
live outside the united states and vote
back home
americans abroad can make a difference
in the states that will decide this
year's elections
we need your help to elect a president
who will restore our spending around the
world
go to vote from abroad.org to learn more
democrats abroad is proud to cast ten
votes for bernie sanders
and seven votes for our next president
joe biden
district of columbia welcome to my
hometown in the best city in the world
washington dc is 706 000 residents
strong
we raise families pay taxes and serve
the united states military
just like every american in the 50
states
the house of representatives just passed
an historic
piece of legislation to make washington
dc the 51st state
from black lives matter plaza the
district of columbia proudly casts
one vote for bernie sanders and 43 votes
for the next president of the united
states
joe biden florida
when my daughter was murdered in
parkland joe biden called to share in
our family's grief
i quickly learned about his decency and
his civility but i also learned about
his toughness and how he's beaten the
nra
together with the other victims of gun
violence and our nation's youth
joe biden and kamala harris will take on
the nra again and win
let's win back our freedom to live
without fear
florida cast 57 votes for bernie sanders
and 192 votes for our next president joe
biden
georgia my mentor congressman john lewis
knew that the right to vote is sacred
georgians know
that our ability to vote is under attack
long lines
voter suppression donald trump is even
trying to slow down the mail
and force us to risk our lives to cast a
ballot we will not be silenced
take out your phone and text vote to 303
30 and make sure your voice is heard in
this election
from the cradle of the civil rights
movement and in the spirit of good
trouble
georgia cast our 117 votes for our next
president
joe biden guam 70 years ago
this summer chamorros became u.s
citizens
we are proud of our resilience proud of
our indigenous heritage
and proud to be part of this historic
moment for our party
and our nation from the land where
america's day begins
guam casts two votes for bernie sanders
and 11 votes for our next president
joe biden hawaii i came from the
philippines to hawaii
the land of indigenous native hawaiians
today i want to speak to my fellow
immigrants
to the essential workers on the front
line to the service members who are our
flag
to the parents with big dreams for their
children no matter where we came from
immigrants belong in our countries long
fight for justice
we belong in the america we are building
together hawaii
birthplace of president obama cast nine
votes for bernie sanders
and 23 votes for our next president joe
biden idaho we're not waiting for
washington to act on climate change
here in boise we know that clean energy
doesn't just mean a healthier planet it
means
good paying jobs imagine what we could
do with the president that listens to
science
and leads with courage idaho casts
nine votes for bernie sanders and 16 for
our next president
joe biden illinois discrimination has
denied
too many black americans the chance to
own a home
and build wealth joe biden has a plan
to end racist lending practices and have
more people of color
achieve the american dream of owning a
home
this isn't just about racial justice
it's about stronger communities
and more economic security for working
families
illinois cast 59 votes for bernie
sanders and 122
votes for our next president joe biden
indiana here in south bend we once
feared that our best days were behind us
but then we reimagined our economy with
new jobs and even new industries
the hoosier state is ready to lead
america's recovery
with our diverse communities our
talented workers and our best in the
world agriculture
joe biden's plan gives us a blueprint to
revitalize industrial cities and rural
areas alike
indiana casts two votes for my friend
bernie sanders
and 86 votes for the next president joe
biden
iowa we were going to talk to you
tonight about biofuels
but the powerful storm that swept
through iowa last week has taken a
terrible
toll on our farmers our small businesses
and our families
who are still without power so while we
have the honor of casting iowa's votes
11 for bernie sanders and 38 to joe
biden
we also want to ask you to keep iowans
in your thoughts during this difficult
time
kansas i'm a fourth generation family
farmer
but i worry about the next generation
many of our
young folks end up moving from a rural
community
to find jobs joe biden has a plan to
help
new farmers get a good start and by
funding schools and health care
he'll make sure that rural communities
remain great places
live work raise a family
generations to come kansas the sunflower
state proudly
cast 10 votes for bernie sanders and 35
votes for our next president
joe biden kentucky one day when i was 14
my mom wouldn't wake up calling 9-1-1 i
was scared not
only because she was sick but because i
knew we couldn't afford the bill thank
god she survived
when i told joe biden that story in 2008
he promised to continue to fight for
folks like us
and got busy passing obamacare two years
ago when mom had a heart attack
we only had to worry about her getting
better because joe
kept his promise the commonwealth of
kentucky cast
all 60 votes for the next president of
the united states
joe biden louisiana this used to be an
abandoned building
now it's a thriving art studio a
community hub
a place where independent artists can
make their name and parents can bring
their kids during these difficult days
of remote learning
our cities are strong because our people
make them strong
and our economy will come back because
our small businesses
will bring it back louisiana cast all 60
of our votes
for my friend and the next president joe
biden
maine my american dream i'm living it a
25-acre organic farm on a lake
a roadside farm stand and a
bed-and-breakfast my husband and i
aren't corporate tycoons we just want to
make an
honest living and feed our community
small businesses like ours are the
backbone of rural economies across
america
joe biden has a plan to help more
americans especially people of color
start their own businesses
maine casts nine votes for bernie
sanders and 22 votes for our next
president
joe biden maryland black lives matter
and when it comes to racial justice
black opportunity matters
when joe biden rebuilds our middle class
he won't leave anyone behind
his plan more capital for black
entrepreneurs more funding for public
schools
hbcus banning racial discrimination in
the housing market
and paying every worker a fair way
that's building back better
maryland the home of frederick douglass
cash one vote for bernie sanders and 119
votes for our next president
joe biden massachusetts we need a plan
to get the economy going again
joe biden will get the pandemic under
control
create new jobs and manufacturing and
clean energy
help small businesses and our
restaurants recover
and build back better so that our
economy is stronger
and fairer than it was before
massachusetts cast 30 votes for bernie
sanders
and 83 votes for our next president joe
biden
michigan auto workers are the best in
the world but we'd be nowhere without
joe biden
and a lot of folks wanted to let detroit
go bankrupt
but joel biden believed in us and
together we fought to save
our auto industry now he's got a plan to
create a million new auto jobs by
investing in clean energy
joe biden believes in american workers
he's got our back
and we've got his michigan cast 53 votes
for bernie sanders
and 92 votes for our next president joe
biden minnesota
i'm here in minnesota the home of the
headwaters of the mississippi river
we know that a bridge shouldn't fall
down in the middle of america but it did
and we came together to rebuild it
that's what we do in america
that's what joe biden will do as
president he'll build
back better he'll cross the river of our
divides and unite this country
from our cities to our suburbs to our
rural areas
and now we will virtually cross the
great mississippi to st
paul to hear from my friend mayor melvin
carter
thank you senator as the 46th mayor of a
city that's more than ready
for our 46th president i'm proud to cast
minnesota's 31 votes for bernie sanders
and 60 votes for our next u.s president
joe biden mississippi tougaloo college
reflects the progression of a people
from slavery to citizenship to
scholarship and leadership
contributing to mississippi and the
world our alumni
are leaders like convention chairman
congressman benny thompson
joe biden wants to invest 70 billion in
hbcus like tougaloo
imagine what impact that can have on
hbcus
imagine what impact hbcus could have on
america
mississippi cast two votes for bernie
sanders and
38 votes for our next president joe
biden
missouri as a member of the
international union of bricklayers
and allied craft workers local one st
louis
i love walking around the city and
seeing the contributions that my
brothers
and sisters have made we stand ready to
rebuild our nation's infrastructure
and with joe biden's leadership we'll
create millions of new jobs
building back better missouri cast 28
votes for bernie sanders
and 50 votes for our next president joe
biden
montana when kovitz shut down my college
i came home to my parents ranch to
finish senior year online
but some days i can't even get a video
to load or an email attachment to send
without reliable internet there's no
remote learning no virtual doctors
appointments
and just try starting a small business
world broadband can be a game changer
for rural communities like mine and joe
biden has a plan to make it happen
montana casts one vote for bernie
sanders and 18 votes for our next
president
joe biden nebraska i work at a meat
packing plant making sure
grocery store shelves stay full they
call us essential workers but we get
treated like we're expendable
workers are dying from koved but a lot
of us don't have paid sick leave or even
quality protective equipment
we are human beings not robots not
disposable
we want to keep helping you feed your
family but we need a president who will
have our backs
nebraska cast 33 votes for our next
president joe biden
nevada working people are the backbone
of our economy
and the key to our recovery joe biden
knows it's not enough to praise them
we have to reward them so let's raise
the minimum wage to 15
an hour empower workers to negotiate for
better benefits and safer workplaces
and make it easier to pay for things
like health care and higher education
i am proud to cast 24 votes for bernie
sanders
and 25 votes for our next president joe
biden
new hampshire hello from the granite
state we trust joe biden
joel provide the leadership necessary to
bring us back from this awful pandemic
joe has a plan to attack global climate
change once and for all
and joel will restore honesty decency
and trust to the white house
reunite all americans and build a better
future for all
the great state of new hampshire awards
nine delegates
to our friend and neighbor bernie
sanders and 24 delegates to the next
president united states
joe biden new jersey we've been hit hard
by covid
but we're coming back but we have to be
smart
we have to listen to the experts and we
have to have a president
who has a plan that's why in memory of
all those we've lost
in solidarity with those who are sick or
struggling
and in eternal gratitude for our heroic
front line workers new jersey cast five
votes for senator bernie sanders
and 139 votes for the next president of
the united states
joe biden new mexico
greetings and good evening my name is
derek lente state representative
coming to you from the homeland of my
ancestors here at the beautiful pueblo
of sandia
new mexico is a diverse state home to 23
indigenous
sovereign nations with a rich
multicultural history
we are all united by the love of this
beautiful place that we call home
and we believe that we owe it to the
next generation to protect the natural
and cultural resources
that are their inheritance and to that
end
also respect tribal sovereignty new
mexico proudly casts
four votes for bernie sanders and 42
votes for the next president of the
united states of america
joe biden new york
as an immigrant from saint vincent and
the grenadines
and an 1199 sciu registered nurse
i am proud to be part of america's fight
against
covet 19. but many health care workers
don't get paid sick leave or have enough
protective equipment
i have two children with asthma and a
mother who's high risk
i worry every day about bringing this
virus home
to them joe biden's plan will help
us take better care of your loved ones
as well as our own
along with lieutenant governor kathy
hokel
i cast new york's votes 44
votes for bernie sanders and 277
for our next president joe biden
it's joe time north carolina
i've been doing this for a long time so
let me just be plain
black people especially black women are
the backbone of this party and if we
don't show up
democrats don't get elected i'm putting
on my math
and we're going to every corner in north
carolina to help organize
because we need to make sure everyone
shows up for joe biden
he will show up for us north carolina
cast
39 votes for bernie sanders
and 83 votes for the next president of
the united states
joe biden north dakota
the dosha dosha jeed
welcome to the homelands of the mandan
hidadza and arikara people
i graduated from a class of just 44
students and i
drive three hours just to take the sats
but growing up
i knew that college was a ladder that
could take you anywhere joe biden knows
that everyone deserves a chance to climb
that ladder
so as a proud tribal member as a
mexican-american as a harvard graduate
i am proud to cast north dakota's votes
ten for bernie sanders
and eight for our next president joe
biden
northern mariana islands half a day tea
roll and hello from paradise the
northern mariana
islands we may be far away but we're
american citizens
and this year for the first time in
decades we finally have a democratic
slate
because democrats organize everywhere
but we don't get to vote for president
so please don't waste yours the northern
mariana islands
is proud to cast two votes for senator
bernie sanders
and nine votes for our next president
joseph biden
siddhis maasi olomai and thank you
ohio it seems like every time working
people
believe in a donald trump promise they
wind up getting screwed
well joe biden has more than just a
promise he actually has a plan to bring
jobs back to america
like electric vehicles are a national
network
of vehicle charging infrastructure
that'll create good paying jobs
for skilled union workers like josh
and the future will be made in america
ohio cast 20 votes for senator bernie
sanders
and 134 votes for the next president joe
biden
o-h i-o
oklahoma 99 years ago racial violence
devastated a thriving black community
here in tulsa
today hatred still lives in our nation
but so does resolve
oklahoma refused to let ourselves be
defined by division then
and our nation must turn back the tide
of violence again
now oklahoma has 13 votes for bernie
sanders
and 24 votes for our next president joe
biden
oregon as black americans standing on
native land we proudly represent
oregon the dual viruses over 19 and
racism
lay fair unequal healthcare access and
deaths in communities of color the
democrats are working to bridge divides
and make sure everyone has equal access
to low or no
cost quality care today oregon
cast 16 votes for bernie sanders and
with signatures wyden and merkley
support
cast 57 votes for joe biden
pennsylvania when joe biden was young
his father came to this house in
scranton
sat down on joe's bed and told him he
lost his job
it's a moment that stayed with joe his
entire life
right now all across america working
families are experiencing that same fear
and uncertainty but joe biden has a plan
to help them
and to help our country build back
better creating millions of good paying
jobs
so more parents will be able to tell
their kids
what joe's dad said to him all those
years ago
it's going to be okay pennsylvania casts
34 votes for senator bernie sanders and
175 votes
for the next president of the united
states scranton's own
joe biden
[Applause]
puerto rico
rhode island rhode island the ocean
state
where our restaurant and fishing
industry have been
decimated by this pandemic are lucky to
have
a governor gina raimondo whose program
lets our fishermen
sell their catches directly to the
public and our state up
appetizer calamari is available in all
50 states
the calamari comeback state of rhode
island casts one vote for
bernie sanders and 34 votes
for the next president joe biden
south carolina mr chairman
i am jamie harrison candidate for the
united states senate
speaking from the campus of south
carolina state university
the alma mater of majority group jim
kleiber and the late dr
emily england clover for whom its honors
college is named
this proud hbcu has contributed 22
general officers
to our armed services and tonight
i proudly cast south carolina's 64 votes
as follows 15 for bernie sanders
and 49 for our next president of the
united states
joe
as a first american and citizen of the
standing rock sioux tribe
i welcome you to the pasapa the black
hills
the site of my creation story and home
to the ocheti shakowi
the great sioux nation we often say
midaku yayasi
we are all related our next president
must lead by this philosophy
for the betterment of our next seven
generations
we cast three votes for senator bernie
sanders
and 17 votes for our next president joe
biden
tennessee 100 years ago tonight
suffragists based here at the hermitage
hotel in nashville
cheered as tennessee became the 36th and
deciding state
to ratify the 19th amendment granting
women the right to vote
this year i'm casting my very first
presidential vote for joe biden
women will decide this election and will
replace donald
trump with the president who respects us
tennessee
cast 23 votes for bernie sanders and 50
votes for our next president of the
united states
mr joseph r biden
a year ago my safe community of el paso
was targeted by a domestic terrorist
who murdered 23 innocent people injured
23 more
and devastated all of us his motive was
racism and xenophobia
in the face of hate we choose love
siempre luemo
and in the face of continued gun
violence in america we demand
change the time has come to act with one
abstention the great state of texas
casts 98 votes for bernie sanders
and 161 votes for our next president joe
biden
utah here in utah we've had mail-in
voting for years
if you're registered to vote you
automatically get sent a ballot
it's fast it's reliable and it's easy
for everyone to participate
in 2016 we had turnout well over 80
percent
and this year we're expecting even
higher that's why democrats and
republicans here in utah agree
mail-in voting strengthens our democracy
utah cast 17 votes for bernie sanders
and 16 votes for our next president
joe biden vermont the state of vermont
strongly believing in economic justice
social justice
racial justice and environmental justice
proudly supporting democracy
and the constitution of the united
states and vehemently opposed to the
authoritarianism
and racism of the trump administration
is proud to cast
15 votes for vermont senator bernie
sanders and nine votes for the next
president of the united states
joe biden the u.s virgin islands
in recognition of our governor albert
bryan jr
and our delegate to congress cece
plaskett we bring you greetings from the
virgin islands of the united states
we're a young alexander hamilton
rosaries the vacation home of our
nominee
with talk waste waters white sand
beaches and friendly people
we cast over 13 votes for joseph r biden
virginia three years ago my beloved city
charlottesville virginia was attacked by
white supremists
and a young woman was killed we were
attacked again
when donald trump praised those racists
turning his back on a community that
just
wanted peace that was the day joe biden
decided
to join this battle for the soul of
america
over time my wife was allah and i have
come to know his soul he's a decent
compassionate man he will bring this
nation together
virginia cost 32 votes for bernie
sanders
and 91 votes for our president
joe biden
washington xinjiao as a 15-year-old
refugee from vietnam
i knew that education was the key to
finding opportunities
in my new home when having children of
my own
i became an advocate to improve the
public education system
that gave me a chance to contribute to
our america
democrats invest in education because we
are committed
to fighting for all kids washington cast
43 vote to senator bernie sanders and 66
votes to our next
president joe biden west virginia
west virginians have changed the
narrative about public education
parents teachers and service personnel
have worked together to fight for safe
and welcoming schools
sufficient funding for classroom
equipment and fair wages for teachers
and school service personnel elections
matter but so does activism
so let's keep fighting to guarantee a
quality education for
all our children and let's elect a
president who will fight alongside us
west virginia cast 34 votes for our next
president
joe biden wyoming after our son
matthew's death
in wyoming joe biden helped pass
legislation to protect lgbtq americans
from hate crimes joe understands more
than most our grief
over matt's death but we see in joe so
much of what
made matt's life special his commitment
to equality
his passion for social justice and his
boundless
compassion for others with three
abstentions
wyoming cast four votes for bernie
sanders and 11 votes for the next
president
of the united states joe biden wisconsin
welcome back to milwaukee wisconsin a
great city on native land on the great
lake it's the
place where i was born and raised right
in the heart of 53206
zip code this is a community that's been
faced with some significant challenges
due to historical injustice but
what many don't see is the joy the
resilience and opportunity that lies
within this community and so many others
across america just like it
where hard-working people are fighting
to provide for their families and to
build a better future
we know that we build a better future
for our nation by channeling wisconsin's
legacy
as the birthplace of the labor and the
progressive movement
and uniting around a bold inclusive
agenda that uplifts every community
in the pursuit of a more just future one
that recognizes health care as a human
right one that tackles the climate
crisis and
takes on racial and economic justice
wisconsin cast 30 votes for bernie
sanders and 67 for the next president of
the united states of america
joseph bidens joseph r biden
delaware long before this train station
bore his name
you'd see joe biden up here on the
platform with the rest of the crowd
on his way to work or going home to his
family that's always been his north star
delivering for families like his own
working people who struggle and
sacrifice to build a better life
nobody has ever had to wonder who joe
biden's in it for
our nation faces dining challenges but
i've known joe biden for 40 years and
there's
nobody i trust more to lead our party
unite our country and restore
our standing in the world what's more
he's humble he tells the truth
he treats everybody he encounters with
respect and bills bridges not walls
he is a leader made for this moment and
the finest public servant i've ever
known delaware is proud to cast its 32
votes for our favorite son
and our next president our friend
delaware
joe biden
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys
[Music]
let's celebrate there's a party going on
right here
thank you to all our delegations i'm
pleased to announce
that vice president joe biden has
officially been nominated
by the democratic party as our candidate
for president
of the united states vice president
biden is hereby
invited to deliver an acceptance speech
well thank you very very much from the
bottom of my heart
thank you all it means the world to me
and my family
and i'll see you on thursday thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
come on that was so sweet with the
grandkids yay
and now we have an official nominee
on to the next step electing joe biden
and kamala harris in november
make sure you have a plan to vote text
vote to 30330 to find out how
now we're going to talk about a topic
that touches all
of our lives healthcare the affordable
care act was game changing
this pandemic has revealed just how
important it is
to protect and improve it increasing
access to health care and bringing down
its costs have
always been a priority for joe biden
because for joe and for all of us
health care is personal
it's the toughest battles that called
for the steadiest leadership
[Music]
again and again they were told to give
up on affordable health care
they knew it would cost them politically
the republicans say this will prove to
be unpopular bill is a legislative train
wreck
but not nearly as much as it would cost
the american people
if they did nothing we are not going to
slow up on providing
affordable health care for americans
health care is a natural american right
giving up
on the affordable care act would have
meant leaving 20 million without
coverage out in the cold
but joe biden wasn't about to give up
because he knew what it was like
to stand in their shoes
he was sworn into the senate next to a
hospital bed
his wife and daughter had been killed in
a car crash
and lying in that bed were his two sons
forty years later one of those little
boys his son
bo was diagnosed with cancer and given
only months to live
it's hard to imagine a greater grief
than losing your child
but joe always knew that his family was
one of the lucky ones
after that accident his son got 40 more
years of life
all because he had health care
without objection to motion reconsiders
laid on the table
[Applause]
now it's unthinkable that donald trump
is trying to take that health care away
in the middle of a pandemic he's still
trying to get rid of the affordable care
act
this fight is personal for joe
as personal as it gets when joe
says he has a plan to strengthen the
affordable care act
protect those with pre-existing
conditions and expand
access to every american he's thinking
about how having health care
saved his boys when his plan talks about
lowering drug prices and making care
more affordable he's thinking about bo
who spent his final days in comfort
because he was insured
joe biden knows what affordable health
care means to american families
because of what has meant to his
this is my promise to you when i'm
president
i will take care of your health care
coverage and your family the same way i
would my own
for that's what the presidency is the
duty
to care to care for all of us
not just those who vote for us but all
of us this job is not about me
it's about you it's about us
[Music]
how are you you handsome boy
he was born in 15 and uh
with a heart condition you know known as
transposition of great arteries
and ended up requiring a transplant
and thankfully the aca had already taken
effect
um but now that's something that we
think about all the times especially
with his
coverage and the potential of coverage
maxes and uh his initial hospital state
was
over three million dollars that was
built back to the insurance
i remember thinking as boley dying in
bed and we'd sit lie in bed with him his
brother and i
and his sister and thinking to myself
what in god's name would i do if the
doctor walked in and said
i'm sorry you've outrun your insurance
you've reached your cap suffer
the last few months of your life on your
own i came from a near a part of the
country
rural missouri uh where basically
everybody was a republican and i was a
republican
and i lost my voice
and uh we put off going to the doctor
because we didn't have the health
insurance
when we finally got into somebody that
could take a look at my
my throat they said well you've got
cancer it was
stage four the worst con cancer you can
have
my wife applied for uh insurance through
the affordable care act
and uh my coverage began on april 1st in
2012
and that same day they started my chemo
and radiation
and uh did save my life i'm here today
um generally speaking as a church you're
concerned about people
spiritually but you're also concerned
about other areas of their life
um and that includes their physical or
physiological
well-being um because the bible talks
about all of us but there are people
in our country and in fact people in my
church
that can't take advantage of it because
they don't have good health care
that's um that's pretty discouraging to
me and that's pretty discouraging to
them
because of the myasthenia gravis and the
fact that it's a very rare disease
a lot of our medications we have to
fight for
and before the aca we worried about our
medications
we worried about the pre-existing
conditions for our children
we worried about age and
the cap because having that cost of the
medications
we would have reached that million
dollar cap in no time
but once the aca passed
we did we no longer had that cap of the
million dollars
the fear that you all live in
on understandably if somehow tomorrow
they said no insurance you can't
you're not covered um it's just uh
it's just devastating hey laura how are
you doing
how are you doing well you beat
hodgkin's lymphoma god love you
but uh during it all trump was trying to
rip away your coverage uh the day you
got your first chemo republicans voted
to gut the aca i can't imagine what it
must have been like
going to sleep at night wondering what
to do ever since i was diagnosed
every night i'd go to bed concerned
about
what news i would get in the morning and
even still even today
they're still trying to take away our
health care
even during a pandemic look we're going
to make sure we don't lose that aca
we're going to provide a a medicare-like
option as a public option
and any state where there is a if you
qualify for medicaid and the state
hasn't provided it you'd automatically
be enrolled
i'm going to protect you like i tried to
protect my own family
my own family and i promise you that
[Music]
i met joe last year at a campaign event
to thank him for
being so involved in the battle of cure
cancer
indeed i have what's been diagnosed as
terminal cancer
the inspiration and the empathy and the
human love that he was shared with me
has kept me going i made an appointment
for my
wellness checkup provided for by the
affordable care act i was told that i
had ovarian cancer
i finished my course of treatment
and since then i've been cancer-free and
i'm very grateful for that
i chose to become a joe biden delegate
as i watched
with our nation as president donald
trump
sought to dismantle the affordable care
act my purpose in life
right now is to devote all my energy to
getting joe elected i anxiously jumped
at the chance to become a fighting
delegate
you will continue to strengthen the
affordable care act
so that diseases like cancer don't go
undetected
[Music]
hey carl it's me dad
by the time you're watching this you
will have grown up to be
strong and courageous but
i don't know how much longer i'll be
around for you
i was diagnosed with als today
which is a deadly debilitating disease
after i was diagnosed the president
passed a tax bill
that put my health care at risk so i
went to washington d.c
my next guest made headlines when he
confronted a republican senator on an
airplane
you can be an american hero i wanted to
help create
a better country for you to live in
democracy is
beautiful
all that matters to me is to make you
proud
because i'm already so proud of you
hello america my name is audi barkin
and i am speaking to you through this
computer voice because i have been
paralyzed by a mysterious illness called
als
like so many of you i have experienced
the ways our health care system is
fundamentally broken
enormous costs denied claims
dehumanizing treatment when we are most
in need
since my shocking diagnosis i have
traveled the country meeting countless
patients like me
demanding more of our representatives
and our democracy
today we are witnessing the tragic
consequences of our failing health care
system
in the midst of a pandemic nearly 100
million americans do not have sufficient
health insurance
and even good insurance does not cover
essential needs like long-term care
our loved ones are dying in unsaved
nursing homes
our nurses are overwhelmed and
unprotected and our
essential workers are treated as
dispensable we live in the richest
country in history and yet we do not
guarantee this most basic human right
everyone living in america should get
the health care they need
regardless of their employment status or
ability to pay
even during this terrible crisis donald
trump
and republican politicians are trying to
take away millions of people's health
insurance
with the existential threat of another
four years of this president
we all have a profound obligation to act
not only to vote
but to make sure that our friends family
and neighbors vote as well
we must elect joe biden each of us must
be a hero for our communities
for our country and then with a
compassionate
and intelligent president we must act
together and put on his desk a bill that
guarantees us all the health care we
deserve
text vote to 30330 to learn how to vote
safely
because our lives depend on it
politics and elections can seem like
these far away things that one person
doesn't have the power to change
but what's happening in our country
right now makes it clear
how personal politics are i've
discovered that when i get informed
and participate my fear gets smaller
voting is a big part of that so knowing
the change you
want vote for the leaders you think will
make it happen
and if you're able if you can help fund
this campaign
please go to joebiden.com and chip in
whatever you can with leaders like joe
biden and kamala harris
we can build back better here at home
and once again
strengthen our nation's security and
standing in the world
[Music]
my name is demarcus gilliard i'm 34
years old and i currently live in los
angeles california i'm a 2009 graduate
of the u.s naval academy in annapolis
and i served on active duty
in the marine corps as an officer for
six years i took an oath
to support uphold and defend the
constitution of the united states of
america
and i know that joe biden in his years
of public service
took a similar oath and he understands
the sacrifice
of the men and women in uniform who are
overseas right now
fighting for the ideals of this nation
that liberty and justice can be extended
to all people
i know that joe biden understands that
at his core
i trust him to lead us on day one into a
greater future
there's nothing more important for me
right now than making sure
that we restore the soul of our nation
and i think that joe biden
is the best person to do that so thanks
joe
hi i'm john kerry for the eight years of
the obama biden administration
we led by example we eliminated the
threat of an iran with a nuclear weapon
we built a 68 nation coalition to
destroy isis
we forged 195 nation agreement to attack
climate change
we stopped ebola before it became a
pandemic
donald trump inherited a growing economy
and a more peaceful world
and like everything else he inherited he
bankrupted it
when this president goes overseas it
isn't a goodwill mission it's a blooper
reel
he breaks up with our allies and writes
love letters to dictators
america deserves a president who is
looked up to
not laughed at donald trump pretends
russia didn't attack our elections
and now he does nothing about russia
putting a bounty on our troops
so he won't defend our country he
doesn't know how to defend our troops
the only person he's interested in
defending is himself
this is the bottom line our interests
our ideals and our brave men and women
in uniform
can't afford four more years of donald
trump
our troops can't get out of harm's way
by hiding in the white house bunker
they need a president who will stand up
for them and president biden
will joe's moral compass is always
pointed in the right direction
from the fight to break the back of
apartheid to the struggle to wake up the
world to genocide in the balkans
joe understands that none of the issues
of this world
not nuclear weapons not the challenge of
building back better after covid
not terrorism and certainly not the
climate crisis
none can be resolved without bringing
nations together with strength
and humility joe understands our values
don't limit our power they magnify it
he knows you can't spread democracy
around the world
if you don't practice it at home and he
knows that even
the united states of america needs
friends on this planet
before donald trump we used to talk
about american exceptionalism
the only thing exceptional about the
incoherent trump foreign policy
is that it has made our nation more
isolated than ever before
joe biden knows we aren't exceptional
because we bluster that we are
we are exceptional because we do
exceptional things
on june 6 1944 young americans gave
their lives on the beaches of normandy
to liberate the world from tyranny out
of the ashes of that war
we made peace and rebuilt the world that
was
and remains exceptional it is the
opposite of everything donald trump
stands for
this moment is a fight for the security
of america
and the world only joe biden can make
america lead like america again
if you agree text join to 30330
thank you
in the situation where presidents make
decisions of war and peace so when joe
biden walks into the situation room
first and foremost in his mind is how
will my decision
impact the lives of the american people
he is experienced he has made the tough
calls
he's got courage he's got tremendous
courage character
judgment and he can be tough i witnessed
it close up
joe biden is decisive and well prepared
for
any issue there's no one more qualified
than joe biden to be sitting at the head
of the table
in this situation we're making decisions
for this country
having sent his son to war i don't think
anyone
can be more ready than vice president
biden
he knows exactly what's at stake when he
sends our troops overseas
biden understands how important it is to
have
allies standing together with us they
are force multipliers
joe biden has a unique ability to
connect with people he knows the leaders
and he's dealt with them for years
knows what makes them tick they trust
him they trust his judgment and they
know that his word is good
i know that biden's personal diplomacy
will save american lives
to build these relationships takes
decades
and to tear them down all it takes is a
tweet
thanks to donald trump our adversaries
are stronger
and bolder donald trump has had a love
fest with dictators including china
and russia he hasn't been standing up to
them at all i served in the united
states air force for 36 years i've led
space squadrons
nuclear missile squadrons and i never
thought i would have a president who is
a danger to national security
president trump has degraded and debased
the presidency and our country in the
eyes of the world the russians offered
bounties
on u.s soldiers i was shocked when i
read that but the president didn't even
ask vladimir putin about it
that's un-american there's something
wrong with that i mean that's a
dereliction of duty
you're failing the troops you're failing
this country the first thing the
president needs to do is find out what
the facts are
this president doesn't care about facts
biden cares
about the safety and welfare of american
service men and women
our military had a policy to maintain
our presence in syria
we actually came to the aid of the kurds
against isis and we helped stop the
advance
president trump told us to simply
abandon the kurds it's shameful
joe biden will be strong against
dictators i've heard him on the phone
with some pretty tough characters
you know you talk about joe biden's
empathy his decency
but joe biden is tough as nails and
everybody knows it
he will do the right thing no matter the
political cost
i've served for two republican
presidents and one democratic president
i have seen
the trump administration make decisions
without any thought
without any preparation that have
massive life and death
consequences at one of the most
defining times in the history of the
world joe biden is
uniquely qualified to be president of
the united states
if you want a strong america you want
joe biden
hi i'm former secretary of state colin
powell
100 years ago a young immigrant left a
dirt farm in jamaica
and set out for america three years
later a ship pulled into new york harbor
and a young jamaican woman gazed up at
the statue of liberty for the first time
they became my parents and they inspired
me to finish college and join the army
this began a journey of service that
would take me from basic training
to combat in vietnam up the ranks to
serve as chairman of the joint cesar
staff
and secretary of state the values i
learned
growing up in the south bronx and
serving in uniform
were the same values that joe biden's
parents instilled in him
in scranton pennsylvania i support joe
biden for the presidency of the united
states
because those values still define him
and we need to restore those values
to the white house our country needs a
commander-in-chief who takes care of our
troops
in the same way he would his own family
for joe biden
that doesn't need teaching it comes from
the experience he shares
with millions of military families
sending his beloved son
off to war and praying to god he would
come home safe
joe biden will be a president we will
all be proud to salute
with joe biden in the white house you
will never doubt that he will stand with
our friends
and stand up to our adversaries never
the other way around
he will trust our diplomats and our
intelligence community
not the flattery of dictators and
despots he will make it his job
to know when anyone dares to threaten us
he will stand up to our adversaries with
strength and experience
they will know he means business i
support joe biden because beginning on
day one
he will restore americans leadership and
our moral authority
he'll be a president who knows that
america is strongest when
as he has said we lead both by the power
of our example
and the example of our power he will
restore america's leadership in the
world
and restore the alliances we need to
address the dangers that threaten our
nation
from climate change to nuclear
proliferation
today we are a country divided and we
have a president doing everything in his
power to make it that way
and keep us that way what a difference
it will make to have a president
who unites us who restores our strength
and our soul
i still believe that in our hearts we
are the same america that brought my
parents to our shores
an america that inspires freedom around
the world that's the america
joe biden will lead as our next
president thank you very much
it was a friendship that shouldn't have
worked
john a former navy pilot just released
from a north vietnamese prison
joe a young senator from delaware but in
the 1970s
joe was assigned a military aide for a
trip overseas
i was a navy senate liaison and used to
carry your bags on
overseas trips the son of a gun never
carried my bags
he was supposed to carry my bags to have
it but he never carried my bags
john and joe traveled thousands of miles
together
the families got to know each other
gathering for picnics in the biden's
backyard
they would just sit and joke it was like
a comedy show sometimes to watch the two
of them
but when john was elected to the senate
as a republican from arizona
they found themselves on opposing sides
we're in different parties we hold
different views on many issues
they'd be going out on the floor and you
think oh these guys must really
really really dislike each other and
they'd be having dinner that night
together
senator biden had great respect for the
institution of the senate
he built relationships that were cordial
that were
personal we've always been willing when
we thought
the other guy was right across the aisle
and lock
arms it's good for the country
it takes trust to get things done
in a divided government and i think with
joe biden
his colleagues knew that your points
were equally valid to him
even if a deal seemed out of reach it
was always
joe who tried to cross the aisle he was
like a natural for that
he just had an ability to find the
common ground but never give up your
principles
for three decades joe was able to move
his colleagues
and find a way forward on violence
against
women banning chemical weapons assault
weapons
and controlling nuclear arms
was a style of legislating and
leadership that you don't find much
anymore
and when millions of americans were
faced with losing their health insurance
it was joe's friend who saved obamacare
by crossing the aisle mccain has
his vote with a thumbs down
john and i have been given several
awards about bipartisanship
we don't understand why you should get
an award for bipartisanship
thank you for your example and how to
remain the same
good guy that you were when you first
got here
most of all for your friendship
my life and the lives of many have been
enriched by it
[Music]
i have a rule that i never think of
anything negative when i'm running
when i set my mind to something i find a
way to get it done
she is so damn tough and loyal
when i met jill i knew
my brother said there's this woman
you'll really like her jill
so i gave her a call and she had a date
that night
you said um do you think you could break
your date oh that's right
and what'd you do well i called and uh
told the guy that i had a friend in from
out of town
and went out with joe
i was 30 and i was a senator and i was a
widower
several years earlier the
tractor-trailer broadside and my
wife and three children my wife was
killed my daughter was killed
i i wasn't big on the whole date scene
thing
but when i met jill i fell in love with
him when i saw her
he said i'd really like to see you again
so he's looking at his calendar and he's
oh thirsty no no i'm really busy no i'm
busy friday
how about tomorrow and i thought buddy
you
just blew your cover she's owned me
since then
the boys fell in love with jill too i'm
brushing my teeth one morning
and they came running in and bowen hunt
said dad
we think it's time we married jill i
swear to god
it wasn't just my heart that was on the
line
i loved the boys so much i had to be
sure that it had to be forever
now i'm going to ask you one more time
will you marry
me she goes like this
okay
put it together put us back together
[Music]
we were raised with the same values
i grew up in willow grove pennsylvania
right outside of philly
my mom was english scottish and my dad
was italian
[Music]
my grandmother made the homemade noodles
that would hang
you know and she'd be drying her noodles
they're a very close family she's the
eldest of five girls
she's kind of like the godmother of all
of us
i think we've all seen the feistiness in
her
there was a bully in my school she
marched
up the street and knocked on his door
and i punched him right in the face
my father fought in world war ii he was
a signalman in the navy
and he was very patriotic
he would take us to watch the blue
angels and he was
so proud we worshiped our mother
i can picture her so well reading for
hours she just
loved to read and that had a great
influence on me
i went to college at the university of
delaware then i taught in the high
schools
i mean i got up every single day so
excited to go
teach when i married joe
i took off time to establish myself as
the boy's
mom we don't use the term stepmother
bowen hunt said no we have a mom and a
mommy
our mommy died this is our mom
and then along came ashley and
our family was complete
when i was growing up mom
was fun
the headbutting started when i was a
teenager
there was some conflicts she dealt with
it by
taking up running
she started to basically run marathons
i never ever doubted that anything she
said remind her she could do
i got to hand her her doctorate degree
in education
at the university of delaware
well let's turn it positive so you you
will
pass it i would say she's not your
average grandmother yeah
she you know she's the grandmother who
wakes you up at like
what was it like 5 a.m on christmas eve
to go soul cycling
yeah we have a lot of stories
yeah she's a prankster she's very
mischievous
like when she goes on a run sometimes
she'll find like a dead snake
and she'll pick it up and put it in a
bag and she'll use it to scare someone
oh that's a classic jill she wasn't
really a washington person and
i don't think ever imagined herself
being part of that
[Applause]
when joe was elected to vice president
i just thought hey i gotta step it up
here
because there are things that i really
care about
having had a father in the military
having a son
deployed in iraq i saw the need to
support
military families dr biden could draw
anyone in and they
felt like they were talking to an old
friend that is one of her super powers
when she was second lady jill told me
that she
would like to continue teaching at
community college
and i said that's insane
you cannot possibly do that i said i
know i can do both jobs
i never saw her on any day of the week
where she wasn't carrying a huge stack
of papers to grade
as second lady she was teaching full
time
for eight years 15 credits a semester
these were students who wanted to be in
your classroom and i
saw their tenacity and they were taking
care of
children just like i had done she gave a
hundred percent
from her energy to the students she's a
great teacher
teaching is not what jill does it's who
she is
jill just simply cares she cares about
other people
[Music]
when beau was diagnosed with brain
cancer
nobody knew what we were going through
the secret service you know they're not
supposed to react to your life or what
you're doing
they would whisper i'm praying for you
[Music]
um it's your strength
that holds this family together
and i know that you will make us whole
again
you never stop grieving ever but you do
have to find purpose
running for president is too tough to
not be together the future first lady in
the united states that's right
there you go dr ryden
is our first lady the country will be
getting
one of the best humans that we have
she has been through some really tough
things in her own life and she knows how
hard it can be
american people are in their heart no
fight like hellfire
we all need community we need to depend
on others for our strength all american
families we all
need each other
[Music]
and now please welcome dr jill biden
i have always loved the sounds of a
classroom
the quiet that sparks with possibility
just before
students shuffle in the murmur of ideas
bouncing back and forth as we explore
the world together
the laughter and tiny moments of
surprise you find in materials you've
taught
a million times
when i taught english here at brandywine
high school
i would spend my summer preparing for
the school year about the start
filled with anticipation
but this quiet is heavy
you can hear the anxiety that echoes
down empty hallways
there's no scent of new notebooks or
freshly waxed floors
the rooms are dark as the bright young
faces
that should fill them are now confined
to
boxes on a computer screen
i hear it from so many of you
the frustration of parents juggling work
while they support their children's
learning
are afraid that their kids might get
sick from school
the concern of every person working
without
enough protection the despair
in the lines that stretch out before
food banks
and the indescribable sorrow that
follows every lonely last breath
when the ventilators turn off
as a mother and a grandmother as an
american
i am heartbroken by the magnitude
of this loss by the failure to protect
our communities by every precious and
irreplaceable life gone
like so many of you i'm left
asking how do i keep my family
safe you know motherhood came to me
in a way i never expected
i fell in love with a man and two little
boys
standing in the wreckage of unthinkable
loss
mourning a wife and mother a daughter
and sister
i never imagined at the age of 26
i would be asking myself how do you
make a broken family hole
still joe always told the boys
mommy sent jill to us and how could i
argue with her and so we figured it out
together
in those big moments that would go by
too fast
thanksgivings and state championships
birthdays and weddings in the mundane
ones that we didn't even know were
shaping our lives
reading stories piled on the couch rowdy
sunday dinners and silly arguments
listening to the faint south sounds of
laughter
that would float downstairs as joe
put the kids to bed every night while i
studied for grad school
or graded papers under the pale yellow
kitchen lamp
the dinner dishes waiting in the sink
we found that love holds a family
together
love makes us flexible and resilient
it allows us to become more than
ourselves
together and though it can't protect us
from the sorrows of life
it gives us refuge a home
how do you make a broken family hole
the same way you make a nationhole
with love and understanding
and with small acts of kindness
with bravery with unwavering faith
you show up for each other in big ways
and small ones
again and again it's what so
many of you are doing right now for your
loved ones for complete strangers
for your communities there are those who
want to tell us that our country is
hopelessly divided
that our differences are irreconcilable
but that's not what i've seen over these
last few months
we're coming together and holding on to
each other
we're finding mercy and grace in the
moments we might
have once taken for granted
we're seeing that our differences are
precious
and our similarities infinite
we have shown that the heart of this
nation
still beats with kindness and courage
that's the soul of america joe biden
is fighting for now
after our son beau died of cancer
i wondered if i would ever smile or feel
joy again it was summer
but there was no warmth left for me
four days after beau's funeral i
watched joe shave and put on his suit
i saw him steal himself in the mirror
take a breath put his shoulders back
and walk out into a world empty of our
son
he went back to work that's just who he
is there are times when
i couldn't even imagine how he did it
how he put one foot in front of the
other and kept going
but i've always understood why he did it
for the daughter who convinces her mom
to finally get a breast cancer screening
and mrs work to drive her to the clinic
for the community college student who
has faced homelessness and survived
abuse
but finds the grit to finish her degree
and make a good life for her kids
for the little boy whose mom is serving
as a marine in iraq
who puts on a brave face in his video
call
and doesn't complain when the only thing
he wants for his birthday
is to be with her for all those people
joe gives his personal phone number to
at rope lines and events
the ones he talks to for hours after
dinner
helping them smile through their loss
letting them know that they aren't alone
he does it for you joe's purpose has
always driven him forward his strength
of will
is unstoppable and his faith
is unshakable because it's not in
politicians or political parties
or even in himself it's in the
providence of
god his faith is in
you in us
yes so many classrooms are
quiet right now the playgrounds are
still
but if you listen closely you can hear
the sparks of
change in the air across this country
educators parents
first responders americans of all walks
of life
are putting their shoulders back
fighting for each other
we haven't given up we
just need leadership worthy of our
nation
worthy of you honest leadership to bring
us back together
to recover from this pandemic and
prepare for whatever
else is next leadership
to re-imagine what our nation will be
that's joe he and kamala
will work as hard as you do every day
to make this nation better
and if i have the honor of serving as
your first lady
i will too and with joe
as president these classrooms will ring
out with laughter and possibility once
again
the burdens we carry are heavy and we
need
someone with strong shoulders
i know that if we entrust
this nation to joe he will do for your
family
what he did for ours bring us together
and make us whole carry us forward
in our time of need keep the promise
of america for all of us
hey everyone i'm jill biden's husband
as you heard tonight excuse me you can
see why she's the love of my life
the rock of our family she never gives
herself much credit
but the truth is she's the strongest
person i know she's a backbone like a
ramrod
she loves fiercely cares deeply nothing
stops her when she sets her mind into
getting something right
and you know for all of you out there
across the country
just think of your favorite educator who
gave you the confidence to believe in
yourself
that's the kind of first lady lady lady
lady
this jill biden will be god love you
so go to joebiden.com to join
our campaign thank you all for watching
i'll see you soon
thank you
[Music]
put it together
[Music]
thank you so much for being a part of
this night
as dr biden just reminded us joe is a
steady and experienced leader who can
bring us together
and help us heal who will support us in
getting better
remember we bend the ark of justice
if we participate if we vote
this moment isn't beyond you it's up to
you
tomorrow night we'll meet joe biden's
choice for vice president
kamala harris and learn more about their
vision for the future of our country
and we'll also hear from senator
elizabeth warren and
president barack obama plus performances
from billy eilish and jennifer hudson
and now
with his song never break here's john
legend
[Music]
whenever life is hard we'll never lose
our way
cause we both know who we are
who knows about tomorrow we don't know
what's in the stars i just know
i'll always follow the light in your
heart
[Music]
so i'm not worried about us
and i'm now the man we know how
the story we will never break
we will never break
build our foundation strong enough to
[Music]
our love will remain we
[Music]
we will never
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foundation strong enough to stay
we will never break
as the water
[Music]
our rises will remain we will
never know we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
tonight is all about leadership we will
work to meet our extraordinary
challenges because progress is made by
the hopeful
not the cynical and we will do that work
together because
movements are built by the many not the
few
faced with a president of cowardice joe
biden is a man of proven courage
he will restore our moral compass by
confronting our challenges
not by hiding from them or undermining
our elections
to keep his job we need a president who
respects our laws
and the privilege of public service
who reflects our values and cares about
our people
in this job interview the differences
start
you know what donald trump will do with
four more years blame bully and belittle
and you know what joe biden will be
build back
better joe understands our values don't
limit our power they magnify it
he knows you can't spread democracy
around the world
if you don't practice it at home joe
biden will be a president we will all be
proud to salute
i know that if we entrust
this nation to job he will do for your
family
what he did for ours bring us
together and make us whole carry us
forward
in our time of need keep the promise
of america for all of us
i'm marianne buddy bishop of the
episcopal diocese of washington d.c and
i'm honored to offer the benediction
tonight
hear these words from pastor civil
rights leader and peace activist
william sloane coffin may god give you
the grace
never to sell yourself short grace to do
something big
for something good grace to remember
that the world is too dangerous now
for anything but truth and too small
for anything but love and now may the
blessing of god the source of
all goodness truth and love
inspire you inspire us all to realize dr
king's dream
of the beloved community congressman
lewis's dream of a just
society president lincoln's dream of a
more
perfect union in this country
in our time amen
delegates and distinguished guests
having concluded this evening's
convention program
we will stand in recess until tomorrow
evening
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you